welcome to hannity tonight millions are
still without power
after this massive winter storm
continues to pelt
the state of texas much of the southwest
now according to reports frozen wind
turbines
and other unreliable sources of you got
it green new energy
are likely playing a significant role in
the widespread blackouts
and coming up texas governor greg abbott
will join us he'll have the very latest
as he has ordered a full investigation
into the ongoing power outages there
also tonight new poll is showing
huge and sustained support for president
donald trump within the republican party
we're going to explain what that means
for the future of the gop
coming up but first the mob the media
their embarrassing love affair with joe
biden
it's only getting worse after five years
never-ending lies smears conspiracy
theories
breathless hysteria directed at any and
all things
donald trump most of the so-called
journalists fake news people are now
taking it easy
just like they did with obama it sounds
eerily familiar
remember that question about president
obama
what do you find enchanting
during these first 100 days what has
surprised you the most
about this office enchanted you the most
about serving in this office humbled you
the most
and troubled you the most let me write
this down
surprise uh trouble i've got uh what was
the first one
surprised surprised troubled troubled
enchanted enchanted
and what was last one humble tumble
thank you sir
even obama's laughing at the softball
question now this kind of hard-hitting
coverage is back
yesterday the reporters fake news cnn
delivered this hard-hitting
expose featuring joe biden's preference
for having a fire in the oval office
fireplace
and get this according to the report
quote
he sometimes adds a log himself to keep
the fire
going wow and that's not all the story
fake news cnn goes on to detail how
biden is an
early to bed type no surprise there
if i had to guess i'm guessing maybe 8pm
bedtime and
after a bedtime story and a little milky
i don't know
following an afternoon nappy but i
digress anyway
now look at this report from newsweek
joe biden playing as
luigi wins in the mario kart race
against the granddaughter at camp david
and this article from politico claiming
historians
and relationship experts agree the first
couple's romantic
gestures aren't just genuine they're
restorative
you know public displays of affection
are now back all thanks to joe and jill
biden not to be outdone this headline
from the washington post reading quote
power up scrunchies and dog walking
the country gets a taste of jill biden's
radical
normalcy now there's nothing wrong with
a few fluff pieces about the president
and his family
but i don't recall this ever happening
under donald trump instead the media
attacked they mocked they spewed never
ending a steady stream
of obsessive psychotic rage and hatred
against donald trump
against his entire family and against
all of his supporters for five plus
years and over and over again they would
jump through hoops to attack the
president and his family
for example last summer when president
trump was calling for
you know law and order to be restored
amid a wave of far left riots and
city after city oh many in the mob the
media pretended the riots weren't
actually happening
during the violence in kenosha for
example yet this is my favorite picture
you got a fake news cnn reporter
standing
in front of literally the city on fire
decked out in protective gear above a
banner reads
you can read it right there fiery but
mostly peaceful protests
after police shooting minneapolis msdnc
not to be outdone you have an anchor
claiming the situation was not
generally unruly while that reporter was
standing outside
another burning building and today our
old friend morning joe
he's back continue to downplay this
summer's carnage
he said you can't possibly compare the
riots
to what happened at the capitol because
only a few measly
taco stands were impacted over the
summer take a look i know they're idiots
on other cable news
channels that will will say well you
know this mom and pop store
was vandalized during the summer riots
and that's just
as bad as the united states capital
being vandal
no no actually no no jack
it's not the capital of the united
states of america
is the center of american democracy and
while i am a fierce believer in people's
right to defend their private property
i'm not going to confuse a taco stand
with the united states capital um
joe do you have any clue at all how many
tacos
that one would have to sell to rebuild
a burned down building or business do
you not
realize the tireless work mom and pop
small business owners put into their
companies you're so cavalierly
it's not as important as the capital
they're all important
we're talking about people putting their
life work every penny
they have to make a their businesses
successful
you have any idea about the level of
death and destruction from the summer
of violence that well your network
pretty much ignored
over 2 thousand police officers injured
remember the
molotov cocktails frozen water bottles
bricks and rocks and knives and
everything else
at least 30 americans killed kenosha
alone more than
35 small businesses all those dreams all
those families were destroyed
and don't forget in minneapolis the
police precinct burned to the ground
and several other private businesses set
ablaze
hundreds of businesses nationwide looted
arson
all told far left riots caused about 2
billion dollars in damage
one might have to wonder how many tacos
is two billion dollars joe maybe you can
do the math
people were killed people were injured
lives were destroyed
dreams literally up in smoke the morning
joe's hatred of president trump knows no
bounds now let's be very clear here
so there is no liberal ambiguity and we
have said from day one
that happened at the capitol on january
6 that breach
was horrific it could never ever ever
happen
again all who committed acts of violence
all who broke the laws
must and will be held accountable every
institution
and every elected official this
transcends politics
republican democrat independent all of
them
must be protected but so should every
home american home
and business and every kid every school
as well
unlike the mob the media will apply this
same standard to those who wreaked havoc
on american cities and americans all
over the summer
unlike the mob yeah as always we're
independent
we're not controlled by the democratic
party or the republican party i'm not
even a registered republican or democrat
i'm registered as a conservative we do
our own investigations
we don't rush to judgment oh let's see
richard jewell
uva duke lacrosse uh ferguson
baltimore cambridge police and the list
goes on and on and on oh and
nicholas sandman don't forget that case
we'll always hold our leaders
elected leaders accountable and of
course that includes joe biden and
tonight
troubling new development inside the
white house that i doubt the media mob
will pay attention to
foxnews.com reporting tonight vice
president kamala harris in fact is
holding
solo calls with leaders on behalf of joe
biden
and while joe has talked to russia and
china why has he snubbed israel
our closest ally in the middle east the
only democracy there
why is kamala acting as
commander-in-chief
are these international calls
interfering with joe's early bedtime is
he not capable of conducting the calls
for some reason
uh is he passing on all that
responsibility to
kamala harris